J'ai beaucoup de responsabilité pour ce que
j'ai créé ces années-ci Je
joue au football Je me considère comme un
modèle Je pense que la clé est d'être soi-même
Je suis moi-même depuis le premier jour Je n'ai pas
changé pour  rien
[Musique]
Je dis toujours crois en toi aie
confiance et ils ont une grande volonté et
tu réaliseras ton rêve quoi que tu fasses
est un
mile important pour qu'ils obéissent à la
forme originale
haha ​​Gasca dr.  Ayers Kaboul et le mélanome
ne peuvent pas sur un yacht tu veux
me connaître mon Bullen je vais laisser tomber
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je suis ici et je suis très heureux et
j'aimerais faire partie de cette histoire et
je suis presque sûr que nous allons entrer dans l'histoire
avec ce club et je suis venu ici pour gagner
je ne suis pas venu  ici pour autre chose
et je suis à peu près sûr que les femmes apprécieront tous
les trophées qu'elles ramèneront à la maison
était incroyable la
la célébration je reçois l'amour je reçois
l'énergie je reçois la motivation était
incroyable
réaliser - pour moi, réaliser
ce que j'ai réalisé, donc sans eux
ne serait pas possible, donc où que j'aille
où que je vienne, j'apporte toujours le
drapeau suédois avec moi et je le soutiens
donc pour moi cette déception désignée
n'existe pas seulement la fierté dans la reconnaissance
et très reconnaissant alors merci
[Musique] [
Musique]
Je vieillis oui mais plus je
vieillis,
mieux je m'améliore  encore
plus je vais essayer de le faire pour toi
[Musique]
Je me sens jeune j'ai dit une fois avant je me sens
comme Benjamin Button Je suis né vieux et
j'étais en train de mourir c'est
sûr alors juste pour dire ne t'inquiète pas
pour mon âge
[Musique]
avec ce tatouage, ce sera un symbole pour
les gens là-bas parce que je me sens
le bienvenu mais je ne pense pas que 15 qui
ne se sentent pas comme tout le monde
que c'est possible et j'en suis la
preuve vivante parce que si je  peut
le faire tout le monde peut le faire Je ne suis pas plus
spécial que quiconque même si
je suis le meilleur dans ce que je fais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
premiers jours mec est dans le web tu les mets
que Michael où va-t-il aller c'est
dans le musée j'ai une
pendaison de crémaillère pour le milieu
[Musique]
toi